[Musik]
dieses Bild das lassen sie jetzt
wahrscheinlich als Mahnmal erst mal
hängen denke ich ich weiß nicht warum
das als Mann mal bezeichnet wird haben
sie haben sie Anzeige erstattet
weil es ja offensichtlich mit Bratensoße
oder ähnlichem beworfen wurde nein also
das sind sie nicht kunstverständlich
genug kommt das zu erkennen weil das ist
nämlich ein Bild von einer der weder
Bratensoße sondern Ölfarbe und
michtechniken verwendet hat dass man
offensichtlich sieht
stimmt es ist keine Bratensoße sind
Fäkalien sogar ja das könnte durchaus
möglich sein also das ist jetzt
Kartoffelstampf nee das ist ein Stück
Butter
ja das heißt schmieren im weitesten
Sinne ist ja Teil der Kunst hier wenn
ich jetzt zusätzlich noch was drauf
schmieren würde
wäre das okay
nee leider nicht wie teuer ist denn
jetzt dieses Bild das kostet 7.200
liegt das an der Inflation das so
durchschnittliche Kunst jetzt auch schon
so teuer ist
nächste Frage das sind wurfbild das
heißt wirklich wurfbildner
Einladung ja unter den heutigen
Voraussetzungen ja aber würden Sie auf
dieses Bild
oder ich habe eine kurze künstlerische
Frage was ist ihre Lieblingsfarbe
[Musik]
aber ist es nicht auch ein Vorteil dass
sage ich mal durch die durch die letzte
Generation Menschen wieder auf Kunst
aufmerksam werden tatsächlich
mit Zerstörung von Kunst werden Sie auf
jeden Fall nicht aufmerksam gemacht
werden ganz im Gegenteil sondern mit dem
Betrachten von Kunst mit Sicherheit aber
nicht mit dem zerstörenpunkt es geht
auch so ein bisschen um die letzte
Generation was halten sie so von deren
Aktion großartig ganz wirklich jetzt ja
das trifft sich gut ich habe etwas dabei
Tomaten so ja doch sie haben doch gerade
gesagt ja wenn ich
jetzt ein Bild bewerfen müsste was wäre
am ehesten das Bild wo sie sagen können
wir darauf verzichten ist nicht ganz so
würde ihn dann eins hinter Glas
entfernen ja also wenn der Künstler sagt
das ist so richtig dann ist es
vielleicht dann an ihnen doch noch mal
darüber nachzudenken ob die Tomate
wirklich fehlt aber ich bin ja auch
Künstler sind sie nicht
natürlich wenn der Galerist auch dabei
hilft ist natürlich ein bisschen arm
aber Protestaktion und jetzt einfach so
drauf zack ich bin der von der
vorletzten Generation ich habe mich hier
festgeklebt
ernst genommen wird man auch nicht ne
haben sie die meine Protestaktion gerade
gesehen ich hätte mir ein bisschen
Kartoffelpüree gewünscht ja so da so
krass bin ich nicht drauf sondern ganz
ehrlich schade wir machen eine
Protestaktion
ich bin von der vorletzten Generation
die ist nicht ganz so krass deswegen nur
in Pulverform es gibt jetzt ein
Protestaktion hallo
[Musik]
klimagerätet und mit der guten Nachricht
gebe ich zurück ins Studio krass oder
Entschuldigung noch mal ich mache das
alles sauber das
[Applaus]
genau ja die Zuschauer mittlerweile fast
alle versteckten Symbole hier bei uns im
neuen Studio gefunden
Illuminati Freimaurer Staatsfunk ist
alles dabei wann wollen wir denn die
eigentlichen Strippenzieher bekannt
geben
was es bei so vielen Abonnenten auf
Youtube boah also ich würde mich
ranhalten